when you drown each foot around it and
then it this way and use the energy
coming in to do the job what I don't
want to do is bring my center of gravity
back foot oh
the beginning you might find easier
shift from bigger steps and stick
but eventually you want to have it where
you're just walking please give them
some distance it's not letting me go so
you would be able to expose that every
time
so this is the ground that thing that's
in everything so he's pushing and I'm
taking that energy it's in the bathroom
it's not in an a-frame my skeletal
system this energy is going in the back
foot thank you he just pushing that back
foot harder and harder so the front
foots here relevant but you can see I
don't have to lean on you give me that
the doctor did capture the conductor and
this step the first one zero therefore
[Music]
he's now pushing weight down he's here
so what I'm trying to do is make the
back foot irrelevant see then backwards
irrelevant
I can move as each foot becomes your
relevant switches between relevance I
don't need any time between that's why I
put this walk
careful you don't wave your feet
relative you see yeah I'm starting to
make this is very relevant right here
I'll show you
so I can't move it it's like a building
or jig I take out the pieces that aren't
holding it up
well this foot is not holding it up not
not any of this room and enough would
you so I do have to have the positive
mid-foot pelvic tilt right no okay
you're gonna put me on my heels okay but
I don't want to start doing this
but if you look at my body I mean the
same tilt that I do the techniques
Sumiyoshi nodding the other weird
[Music]
watch the just lowering for lowering
state it won't do anything
you kind of do it on your toes in
correct solution okay just rounding
whatever's touching it's not a bracing
angle and let me stay dynamic okay
that's what's going on with my ground
bed but there's more to it I have to be
able to move mass and therefore I have
to have a weapon relate to what I just
did the weapon like a punch does not
make contact at the end of its range so
I don't punch like that that's a drill
punch that much here makes contact
Edie kgs a much closer range who pushes
through
so in this drill enjoyed the same and
I'm gonna find out where this is okay
here
here and I'm going to move so this is
the Brownback pre-drilling you slept
long because that's in the form so we're
doing the last drill I'm grounding on
the back foot with the weapon
I shoot weight on the front foot don't
use your no one it's all in the body
body diagram using vertical plane so I
have the edge the edge to the middle of
one half okay
this edge line is a dog line the middle
of one half the city in line here's
where you have that Gigi
[Music]
you know what your hands
to be
same places your elbow in terms of those
lines because it doesn't have the yahoo
integration so you never have to add
with your elbow on your shoulder the
elbow is going to come in right or
elbows in this technique is as I said
this is not the ski this is this part of
the punch so I don't I'm not want to go
to here on this drill the elbow is going
to stay at the yard line and the hand is
at the midline that way you can
transition to a young face so here
don't don't make something magic out of
your Center those of us over here locked
here body tight boom then the back foot
some energy please here I'm not bracing
it off me
it's just under me
since I'm vectoring off the back flip
the front foot is your relevant and
therefore it's free to move I don't want
you to transition to young faces with
the half
[Music]
so I can go slow just work on the
dynamics or percussive it gets me closer
to the technique
okay dislike why not punch I don't punch
with my shoulder in the way to guarantee
I know you guys I lower the shoulder
blade scapula we see the difference
lower the scapula
then whoa it's going to be more
connected to my body so the same thing
here
no lower the scapula and it's going to
bring this arm close to my body my lap
is closed don't open it
hold lower and then drill very light
here compress it's the same thing I'm
doing a punch on here don't flare it out
straight elbow a lot close same thing a
lot close to the button then don't
confuse this with the other drill so if
I go on like this there's no way I just
you're doing what I've said because you
move the back foot and say you weren't
vectoring off the back foot the back
foot is state
this is not that just like this is not
that here
let's go this man in there this drill
drill eyes - purse it's going to
acclimate him to the weapons he's too
afraid of it when we start he has to get
used to it
no no different than when we desensitize
them to strike okay I'm not going to
kill him he's also learning what an
attacking body looks like over and over
okay what I'm going to do in this drill
is start here and make that and then hit
that last drill dynamic so this would be
strong I'm going to start here and boom
the other side starting here and
make sure you don't cave that footed
that ankle must be coming out of the
foot even when I have this extended leg
wait the ankle comes out of the foot
straight out of the foot not like this
it doesn't matter if you if you want to
lock these the same drill okay listen I
can use the grid to tell me if my hand
ended up here then clearly I use my arms
to create the effect in here if my hat
goes back like this then I brought it
forward
I used my arms in the technique okay so
what does that look like I want I want
you to move that's what happens I've
become so interested in moving him like
I saw the teacher move now then I throw
form off the window so I bought this and
then you let yourself deviate so you can
look I'm not Brown vectoring I'm here
doing that winding up that's arm
you can look at your hat you go like
this it's not in front
that was your arm order to watch when I
hit him and my hand went back and then
my hand came forward all infrared all
power seeping out your technique so this
move goes only to here it does not get
deflected off within goes through him
because of the victory of the ground
there's no need to go forward because
he's being displaced by the moving
forward of the other novel becoming
relevant leg
each other getting stopped okay brace
which dismissed a crown
okay now we work on the etosha so it's
doing the same thing if you pay
attention so establish the two G go
around it and then we're gonna learn
here to achieve two parts this is a
segue from the last drill so I
established the grounding foot do G
around it and
this is not where you start underneath
underneath then reconcile this one
that's how you decide in there I just
got to make sure it's not off on this
side it goes underneath then around down
here
contact the sharper your duty is the
less effect you're going to have you can
increase effect by other means though so
he's when he is coming faster my weapon
is going faster the inertia of the
acceleration the velocity on the end I
can have a pretty great effect here and
in fact they vary why Gigi becomes less
effective because it takes more time but
here we are static so when I come up and
my GG is very close to the reconcile
form this very little effect so when
your static try to keep it big you see
and then you do the ticking keep it big
then the take
make sure you renew Yoshi is actually
including its angle deviation so some of
you are going there straight there's
some sense that I am going around his
point here that allow us to more
repeatedly cultivate the skills that are
within the specific techniques used in
the set there's not a one-to-one
relationship between all this is how I
do the first move of the set that no
they're working on skill sets that are
in the first tactic okay so my is a
little different timing is a little
different what we're trying to do is
measure for leaks in energy on our part
meaning there's not really a thrust to
it which is the intention the intention
of the first tactic is a spinal
displacement through a thrusting
maneuver if energy swung backwards were
enabled to be pushed backwards or are
bouncing off I'm not able to do and I'm
not doing the first tactic then he does
not have to do his first tactic which is
begin reconciliation and
manifestation because I just bought us
all so in this one you're going to have
to make a shift as we do the atashi part
so this is Part B of the last drill okay
because on this one on the part a I was
just doing this part do you pay
attention my Center has not dropped nor
does my front hand drop and what I'm
going to do instead is lower my Center
and drop my hands underneath my Center
so I have to do G and down you can see
it wait bubbles do not do the technique
do micro drill be okay of the last row
[Applause]
if you get in your tushie using the
broadside of your weapon to push through
his house and Injury Center and the keys
at the end of that in the tactical
meaning if I start to see here there's
no village plush I have to hit his hands
to the center using this broad side boom
and says he's at the end okay so we're
gonna leave this key off make that a
Parsi of this last room this is just the
boss and you see okay let's try
repeating what Michael drilling is I was
just testing for this kind of driving
integrity I wasn't it's not ski is not
the set so here
what my micro journal is trying to see
is can I use in the pushy angle from
here in a minute in Center it's not
trying to move up and is not trying to
decision so you say he's moving back to
not fall just fine but it's not me it's
not dumb
don't move back to my blood that's me
moving him back can you see that yes
yeah okay so why is it important that I
have the check on this Center obviously
I'm afraid even the kana logic was
bandaged he's got to uncheck himself but
I'm also setting up the ski there has to
be some resistance to the ski if he's
fighting it backwards for example
there's no see if he's coming forward
for a moment
Barsky you see that so every time you do
a ski you can't be happening your
opponent free they must be checked in
such a way that it adds the necessary
distance to the penetrated element of
the ski okay so this looks like it works
but it doesn't work as he just rides it
so we're going to see now you're going
to feel what this shift okay
someone shifts from his yarn to his head
and that's where my dog's incision so I
have to do the last rugby check him once
I feel him come off of the sagittal
resistance boom on Phillip with the
young of my technique so my hand will
end up over here into the other young
face on my brain
some common mistakes is you duck you're
not doing what we're saying
so the technique contact go wrong with
push into his center then projector
that's the technique contact go around
in push in dead center
[Music]
what we do instead is there's no center
here and now I have to use the young
face against the young face and this is
what we had never seen you see I brought
the hip with the right arm
while Isis
the hip actually goes the other way and
the llamar so we
the transition from yin to yan should
feel effortless otherwise its young
beyond so if you are that person is
still down because you didn't do the
other boost you didn't check the center
it is balanced going having them trying
to regain it you have to use this to
push him
this weapon goes this here
my hips are wicked so move here not here
so it once also aside from the tip when
I go like this
come over here
I have a shiitake to the front and you
can flick me and I'm going to go over
Oh
[Music]
when you see this when you pick it up
you're going to start stepping out of
the technique so this is an external I
think it all up and as we already said
the juji's gets sharper they are shorter
but every
Hey
my animation girl what's up he is doing
the affirmation grow mentally then he's
going to smush
I'm not going like this right there's a
hand strike and he's protecting
okay let's go watch what's happening
slow one cross the other cross and I
made the other cross V wine watch his
movement in relation to strike one cross
he goes other cross and I don't change
the cross that's how I got here doc one
cross other cross other cross he's
nowhere near my hands I don't need the
tsuba if he hits the tsuba he checked me
enough for this T okay so he goes okay I
just want the other cross okay
but if he goes half-ass this is just
never and right he has to come and get
my hat
okay